let's find out what the shadow cabinet
view shall we because Ed Miller Band who
is the shadow energy and climate change
secretary is here this morning they've
unveiled a new green policy I haven't
either I'm sure you'll be very keen to
talk us about in a moment I just want to
get your reaction time to burn them
there would you be pleased to see him
back in Westminster definitely and he's
doing a brilliant job as mayor of
Greater Manchester and I think what you
see right across the country is labor
local Authority leaders labor Mayors if
you like showing what can be done what
can be done if you're in power but Andy
is a great talent for our party and he
can serve Us in multiple ways okay right
let's talk about your uh policy you're
announcing today a labor government
would deliver Net Zero for electricity
by 2030 talk to us about a zero carbon
power system this is a world leading
commitment that we are making and why
are we doing it Sophie it will make a
difference in a number of ways first of
all it will cut people's energy bills
because let's be clear about this the
only way to get out of this fossil fuels
crisis the only way to cut bills is
green energy green energy is currently
nine times cheaper than gas that's
Renewables like wind and solar they're
nine times cheaper than gas so it will
save 93 billion pounds of bills over the
coming years it will give us energy
security we won't be relying on Putin's
gas for example homegrown renewable and
nuclear power thirdly it'll create jobs
half a million jobs for our country and
it puts us in the Forefront of the fight
against the climate crisis so it's the
kind of radical action we need and
crucially and this is a contrast with
last Friday it is about building an
economy that works for the many right
across our country not about building an
economy which is for a few at the top of
our society you say it's radical at the
same time the government has has also
committed to Net Zero electricity by
2035 it's just five years earlier right
well it's five well just five years I
mean five years is a long time we're in
a decisive moment and look people so how
much will it cost to do it five years
earlier then well here's the thing the
vast majority of this will come not from
the taxpayer but will come from private
investment you see private investors are
lining up to go for wind energy and so
energy but but they can't because
government blocks them on onshore wind
blocks them on solar and doesn't make
the Investments that we need what will
the cost be just explain the the well so
we've made a pledge of a 28 billion
pounds each and every year a a green
Prosperity plan pledge we think this
will cost around 2 billion a year to
make this happen so a small proportion
of that pledge and it is the right thing
to do for the country and crucially you
know if I've been on your program 10
years ago your program wasn't on 10
years ago if I'd if I'd been on 10 years
ago I would have said look green is the
ethical choice
and it's it's the right thing to do for
the long term it's the ethical choice
and the economic choice now now it's
such a contrast with the government
because they say well the answer is
fracking and all these things which will
not make any difference to bills and
aren't safe you talk about affordability
and obviously everyone I think or the
vast majority of people would accept
that green energy uh and is and
Renewables is a key part to
affordability but at the same time if
your focus was just on affordability
you'd be looking at everything wouldn't
you you'd be looking at Green Renewables
yes you would but you'd also be looking
at North Sea uh oil and gas you'd also
be looking at fracking too because don't
you just need to look at the no you
wouldn't it's really important to
explain this to people look gas is sold
on a global market the price we pay for
North Sea gas or fracked gas if that
ever happens is exactly the same as we
pay for imported gas don't take much
just a second don't take my word for it
quasi-quarting the chancellor said it
will make no difference to price that
it's it's an illusion Supply overall
pie and so that is whoever is producing
oil and gas who isn't Putin that is
going to benefit isn't it no I mean look
we've got to use the North Sea we're
going to be carry on using the little C
but if what you're asking me is is
fracking or some dash for gas in the
north C going to be the answer it is not
going to be the answer but it won't
bring down prices and this is the key
thing and on fracking I've got to say
Sophie I mean you know it's obviously
been slightly lost because of the
appalling budget we had on uh Friday
from quasi-cotting but the idea that the
government that promised in the 2019
general election not to restart fracking
unless it was safe now is going to do so
and what is their excuse well they say
not that they found out it's safe but
they're a bit more risk is a price worth
paying for people across our country it
just says it all about this government
they stand up for the fossil fuel
companies they don't stand up for the
British people so you say that you want
to spend 28 billion pounds a year on
either kind of green energy deal
um at a time when borrowing it is at the
levels that it is partly of course
because of uh government policy but
let's be frank mainly because of what
we've seen with inflation energy bills
and so on as well we know that you would
also like to freeze bills is spending 28
billion pounds a year a sensible thing
to do absolutely it is and I'll tell you
why it is and you see it with the policy
I'm announcing today that the whole
reason we're making this investment is
we get a return and what you're going to
be hearing from labor this week is not
just today's plan on a 2030 zero carbon
power world leading plan but you're
going to be hearing a series of policies
from me from Rachel Reeves from
kirstarma about how making those
investments will create the jobs across
our country that we need get us ahead in
the global race you see the difference
between us and the government is not
whether we need growth yes they've had
an appalling growth record I'm fine I'm
glad they're finally admitting it the
question is how do you create that
growth they say tax cuts for some people
at the top for Millionaires and bankers
is going to create the growth the wealth
will trickle down to everybody else but
we know that's being tried in the past
and totally failed we say something
different
you build you build the economy from the
ground up by making these Investments
and today is Phase One the first
building block at the same time they
look the the evidence on tax cuts is
mixed and greatest mix well if you look
at you know Reagan for example they
would point to in the states
what's going on I want to pick you up on
this hang on a second the international
monetary fund right hardly a kind of
group of kind of Looney lefties the
international monetary fund says that
actually if you look increasing the
incomes of the top share of the top part
of our society does not lead to higher
growth quite the opposite okay so would
a labor government reverse the 45p
account well look we've said we're
against it uh we said it's the wrong
thing to do let me just tell you why
it's the wrong thing to do giving it
giving a 50 giving a 50 000 pound tax
cut to millionaires in that country is
not the right answer so now tax policy
just let me answer the question I think
I'll I'll you'll be pleased uh Kirsten
and Rachel Reeve set out tax policy but
and Kia will be saying more about this
quite shortly but let me be clear we're
going to be consistent in our election
Manifesto without opposition to the 45p
tax cuts we think it's the wrong thing
to do for the country understood how
about the 19p cut the cut from 20p to
19. no we don't think that should be
reversed because you know remember that
when we're talking about this basic rate
cut I mean that's people start paying
that at 12 and a half thousand so you
disagree with Andy Burnham then well I
don't think we should reverse that tax
cut look the point is the government has
raised taxes on ordinary families by
massive amounts The Institute of fiscal
study says that even with that tax cut
from 20 to 19 ordinary families will
still be paying more in taxes in fact
everyone up to 155 000 pounds we're
paying more tax than at the start of the
pond so we don't we won't be reversing
that okay understood now if you ask Liz
trussex to sum up in a word what their
government was all about a word yes we
know well I know I can imagine what your
word might be but their word would be
growth right what would be your word to
sum up what this labor government
but look it says on my account for the
backdrop a fairer Greener future and
that is what we're about yeah fairness
because we don't think that as you look
at the problems our country faces that
the answer is lifting the bank bonus cap
or tax cuts for millionaires cost of
living crisis the NHS so fairer Greener
and the two go together and they produce
not only fairness but prosperity for our
country do you think that
there is a I guess some would say that
labor hasn't been bold enough going
forward on setting out what you would do
if you're in government on strikes for
example are you for against strikes do
you think that do you think that there
is a need for labor to be a little bit
more radical well look I think you know
I I was sort of leader of the opposition
so I've got some experience I've got
some previous on this you know it's
there's a sort of there's a kind of
cycle to these things that you know at
the beginning of the parliament you'll
you tend to be less specific more
thematic I think what you're seeing from
labor this week and what you're going to
see in the coming days and the first
thing today you know this is a bold plan
we're announcing I mean you know no
other country no other major country in
the world has said what we are saying
today that by by 2030 we'll have a zero
carbon power system I mean that is a big
deal and you're going to be seeing a lot
more of that in the days to come we'll
be seeing a lot more of kirst armor as
well as someone that has been described
as boring According to some Anonymous
briefings um can you I'm sure I was
described as actually probably not
anonymously either can you tell us
something surprising about kirst armor
something surprising
you know actually I think what you see
with kirst armor is what you get and
actually I think the British people want
that and why is that
dependability decency Integrity somebody
who's going to do the right thing for
the country and you know we had the
years of Boris Johnson we had somebody
who you know broke the rules broke the
law did all the did all those things
no we're not but I think people want
someone to decency Integrity who knows
where he came from and knows what he's
in politics for look he looks at this
country and sees deep Injustice and he
says we're going to change this economy
we're going to change this country and
you're going to be hearing a lot more of
that from him this week you mentioned
that you've been a labor leader yeah I
remember it very well
I'm sure well most of the time anyway
I'm sure all the time all the time now
have you given case time or any advice
on how to cope with I guess some of the
pressures of being leader I mean I sort
of think he doesn't need my advice I
think the only thing I'd say is and it
goes to your the question you just asked
me which is
don't pretend to be something you're not
and that and that's what's been very
good about kids leadership do you think
you did that a bit
more uh no I mean I think probably what
what I mean sort of you know but this is
sort of ancient history but you know in
a way I said I wish I'd been Bolder uh
as labor leader maybe I felt too much of
the weight of the the office you know
too felt too constrained but I think you
know I think Big Ideas are our friend in
politics I think I think people in the
country and remember it's about people
in the country they you know I I lost
election 2015. since then we've had the
brexit referendum we've had all kinds of
things that have happened in our country
I think all of them show one thing
though so many people say the economy
the country doesn't work for me what are
you going to do to make life better for
me what are you going to do to change
things for me and I think that's where
Labor's Focus needs to be do you think
he's got a better chance of winning an
election than you did yes yes definitely
um and look I think the thing about Kia
is that people can see him as a credible
prime minister uh and I think they're
going to be seeing this week the ideas
the things he cares about that he wants
to do if he was to win that election
okay thanks very much